hi in this video I will talk about
regulatory t-cells a regulatory t-cells
are one of the cousins of cd4 positive T
helper cells in this video I would first
talk about T regulatory cell development
then how t regulatory cell identity and
the maintenance of the dealer will
resell I identity happens sick then I
would talk about T regulatory cell
function now first of all to define the
role of T regulatory cell in immune
system I would say T regulatory cell
maintain the homeostasis of immune
response so the balance between
inflammatory and anti inflammatory
response is maintained by T regulatory
cells because there the principal immune
suppressor cell in absence of T
regulatory cell the balance trip over to
an inflammatory response
this increases the chance of severe
inflammation and also increases the risk
of autoimmune disorders which could be
pretty dangerous for our human body now
let's take a look at how the T
regulatory cell develops just like
normal t-cell and b-cell the development
starts from the bone marrow where
hematopoietic pluripotent stem cell give
rise to lymphoid progenitor and the
lymphoid progenitor interns give rise to
t-cell precursor t-cell precursor
migrated to the thymus and inside the
thymus there are sequential stages of
t-cell development at the end the
immature T cells we shall learn to
recognize peptides loaded on MHC class 2
molecules start expressing cd4 plus Co
receptor and down regulates expressing
and down regulates cd8 co-receptor and
these cd8 positive T cells become T
helper cells among these cd8 positive
cd4 positive T cells some of them
becomes T regulatory cells though the
mechanism of how these some pool of
these cd4 positive cells become T
regulatory cells
is not clear but there are some insights
to it now it's a million dollar question
that how some city for T cells become T
regulatory cells so what is so different
about T regulatory cells it turns out
that apart from TCR and T cell receptor
and cd4 co-receptor T regulatory cell
expresses high levels of interleukin-2
receptor alpha chain also it expresses
the transcription factor of four can't
form family Fox p3 and they maintain the
high level of this transcription factor
level now Fox p3 is the lineage marker
for these TV Beulah Tory cell and Fox p2
3 is known as the master regulator which
converts a cd4 positive T cell to a T
regulatory cell like fate it has been
seen that Fox P deletion in the germline
ultimately lead to improper development
of the T regulatory cell and increases
the probability of autoimmune disorders
on the other hand side the opposite is
true if you over expects for a Fox p3 in
a cd8 positive T cell and it would give
rise to a t regulatory cell like
character and start expressing
interleukin 10 I understand now
scientists think apart from this genetic
predisposition there could be other
epigenetic mechanisms which can lead to
T regulatory cells specification a
recent study has shown that a very small
portion in the DNA which is presenting
all the T cells which are generally
methylated are found to be unrelated or
D methylated in case of T regulatory
cells that means they are accessible to
many transcription factor so a lot of
transcriptional programs that is
happening in the T regulatory cells
could be very different from a normal
cd4 positive T cell now Fox p3 gene
contains several introns and there are
several evolutionary conserved
coding sequences presenting these
introns and those are found to be
enhancer one of them is CNS - which is a
enhancer sequence which maintains the
high level of Fox pee throughout its
lifetime
throughout the like lifetime of a
deregulatory cell now the question is
once are T regulatory cell becomes a T
regulatory cell how its identity is
maintained how it doesn't switch to its
earlier precursor form so how the
identity is maintained it has been seen
when the cd4 positive cells switch into
cd4 positive T leg cell then there is a
high expression of Fox p3 which is
maintained throughout its lifetime so
Fox p3 expression a high level of Fox p3
expression could be a key to this
question now maintenance of the T cell
regular identity depends upon signals
from TCR signals from interleukin 2
signals from tgf-beta all these things
leads to higher level of Fox p3 in the T
regulatory cells and all these things
give rise to our T regulatory cell fate
now T regulatory cell has important and
the inflammatory function so here is a
macrophage now macrophage can generally
secrete pro-inflammatory cytokines such
as il-1 il-6 now T regulatory cell
engage with macrophage and prevent them
for secreting these cytokines in this
example macrophage can also regulate
other and help activation of other cd4
positive T cells and thereby activation
of other immune components but T
regulatory cell interacts with the
macrophage and thereby preventing the
macrophage from activating another t cd4
positive T cell also the T wave Ogletree
cell can directly compete with cd4
positive T cell
for interleukin 2 interleukin 2 or il-2
is important for development of both a
cd4 positive T cell and also T
regulatory cell now if there is a
scarcity of iron - then cd4 positive T
cells won't be developed that much also
directly the T regulatory cell can
secrete tgf-beta
and il-10 now interleukin 10 is a
prevalent immune suppressor cytokine
that can act on cd4 T cell and other
inflammatory mediators to check down
inflammation also by using perforin and
granzymes mediated pathway a t
regulatory cell can cause destruction of
these helper cells now here we will
discuss that how t regulatory cell
suppress a macrophage or other antigen
presenting cells function first of all
the secrete Isleton which directly act
on the macrophages or other antigen
presenting cell otherwise they have an
inhibitory receptor known as CTL F 4
which interacts with cd8 T or 86 and
ultimately give rise to a signal to the
nucleus which prevents the expression of
several pro-inflammatory cytokines and
thereby in thereby the inflammatory
response is reduced now T cell also play
a very important role in preventing
water immune disorders now non-obese
diabetic mice is a model for autoimmune
diabetes or diabetic disorder
now if these mice are this month these
mice are generally prone to develop
autoimmune diabetes now if this Mouse
are infected with T regulatory cell then
the onset of diabetes is really delayed
that means T regulatory cell can prevent
the early onset of several autoimmune
disease proof by providing its
anti-inflammatory risk
so this contribute is a video on this
topic if you like my video give a thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you